laurent lafon et moi-même nos deux
commissions
affaires économiques l'audition en suite
des événements du stade de france du 28
mai dernier et nous accueillons un
plaisir ce matin
devant présentant des scènes cf tout
particulièrement son président directeur
général monsieur christophe a dit cheikh
est présent madame sylvie charles quint
des lectrices de transilien qui est
également présent mais aussi pour la
ratp monsieur philippe martin qui est
directeur général adjoint en charge des
opérations de transport et de
maintenance ainsi que monsieur jérôme
harnois que le directeur chargé de la
préparation aux crises des enjeux de
sûreté de conformité et des affaires
institutionnelles
j'aime bien venu à vous au sénat ce
matin je vous informe que nous votre
audition et retransmise en direct par le
sénat à travers son site internet
ensuite les images sont parfois
réutiliser soit par public sénat soit
par d'autres chaînes de télévision en
cas de
publicité ou de reportages
madame messieurs
la france est habitué d'accueillir de
grands événements sportifs
elle en a des qualités et la capacité de
le faire et naturellement
à la tête des infrastructures qui sont
les vôtres vous participez en cela à
l'organisation de ces événements et vous
êtes même pour ne rien cacher en
première ligne pour permettre le bon
déroulement de ces manifestations
le 28 mai dernier vous le savez
peut-être encore plus que les autres
vous étiez évidemment engagés à
l'occasion de la finale de la champion's
league et nous avons vu malheureusement
ce qui s'est passé à l'occasion de ce
match de football les incidents ont eu
malgré tout un impact très très fort à
la fois médiatique mais une chose mais
ce n'est pas la seule chose mais sur
notre capacité en cause notre capacité
jeudi nôtre parce que je m'intègre comme
français dans cette action enfin nous
nous intégrons s qualité comme français
dans cette action un impact fort en
terme d'image et singulier pas d'image
mais de capacité à pouvoir organiser de
tels événements dans d'excellentes
conditions d'autant plus que ce sont des
événements sportifs
dont le but premier est d'abord j'allais
dire le sport a pas l'oublier et le côté
convivial des choses
plusieurs sujets sont sont en discussion
d'abord il semblerait qu beaucoup de
monde concentré un seul endroit
qui est commencée a occasionné les
difficultés de filtrage des capacités
d'accueil au sein du au sein du stade
des questions de billets qui étaient
pour partie faux mais là naturellement
ça n'est pas votre sujet direct
et puis semble-t-il des questions de
communication entre les organisateurs
pour
parfois même de dernière minute lié en
particulier à cette grève qui était
annoncé sur une partie des transports et
singulièrement sur le rer b avec les
décisions de transférer sur le rrd est
donc
là aussi peut-être des questions
d'anticipation je dis peut-être parce
qu'on attend naturellement vos réponses
et on tient ces propos de vos
prédécesseurs pas de ceux qui vous ont
précédés dans différentes auditions
sur ces deux points le nombre de
personnes transportées à l'aller et au
retour du stade et la coordination avec
les autorités de police et la fédération
française de football sur la gestion des
flux
nous interroge etc nous sommes très
intéressés de savoir ce que vous en
pensez sur la manière de fait a confié
me décrire ce qui s'est passé ou comment
les choses se sont organisées ensuite
comment elles se sont passées
d'autres sujets comme des incidents de
sécurité de sécurité publique ont aussi
eu lieu je ne mets même pas au
conditionnel puisque tout le monde admet
aujourd'hui que des actes de délinquance
ont été commis de façon peut-être mais
massive et de ce fait
ce n'est pas contestable à la fois
contre les supporters qui venait
évidemment au stade mais aussi parfois
même contre les personnels vos
personnels de la sncf ou la ratp dans
les gares et les transports à l'encontre
des voyageurs sur ce point vraiment nous
avons besoin de vos lumières nous
insistons fortement car c'est le sujet
qui à ce stade
est établi sur ses principes mais n'est
pas vérifiée sur ce quantum sur ce qui
s'est passé réellement et là dessus on a
vraiment besoin de nouveaux
éclaircissements je ne sais d'autant
plus que se pose la question de la
conservation des images
ça reste un sujet que nous avons relevés
sur qui on s'est interrogé dès les
premiers jours relevé singulièrement la
semaine dernière en apprenant que
notamment
au stade de france il n'avait conservé
aucune image vidéo qu'ils avaient pu
collecter et naturellement la préfecture
plus nous dit qu'elle même a conservé
ses images en attendant de les voir
puisque on nous l'a proposé évidemment
mais vos images à vous les avez vous
conservé en avez-vous dans quelles
conditions vous en avez et
manifestement vous n'avez pas reçu de
réquisition pour les conserver est ce
vrai
si ça ne l'est pas me dites le nous ça
nous intéresse mais il ya quand même un
sujet important sur ce point voilà les
propos qu'il faut propos introductif que
je voulais faire au nom de laurent lafon
à moitié des choses et des collègues des
commissions en vous proposant peut-être
débuté par par vos supérieurs de la sncf
par l'excusé mois mais
faut que je mette un oeil sur le côté
par vous monsieur fanny chez au titre la
sncf s'il vous plaît
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénatrices et
les sénateurs permettez moi tout d'abord
de vous remercier de nous avoir invités
à nous exprimer devant vos deux
commissions concernant les événements
survenus le 28 mai dernier et ses
voyageurs et la société du groupe sncf
qui regroupe toutes les activités de
transport ferroviaire de voyageurs et
dans le cadre notre activité transilien
dirigée par sylvie charles qui est à mes
côtés nous exploitons pour le comptes
d'ile-de-france mobilité la ligne d du
rer et nous courent exploitons ligne b
avec la ratp
l'infrastructure partie sud jusqu'à la
gare du nord relèvent de la ratp la
partie nord depuis la gare du nord
relèvent de sennecé bout et je salue
sens de notre rôle
il me faut à titre liminaire rappeler
que notre rôle dans ce type d'événement
consiste à acheminer les voyageurs dans
de bonnes conditions jusqu'à la gare
d'arrivée proche du lieu où se tient
l'événement cela veut dire un plan de
transport adapté à la fréquentation
attendue en toute sécurité et avec la
bonne information notre rôle commence et
s'arrête donc aux bandes de nos gars la
préfecture de police et les
organisateurs
gère quant à eux l'orientation des
spectateurs entre les gares et le stade
de france je pense qu'il est essentiel
de le rappeler je veux indiquer que nous
avons une longue expérience des
événements au stade de france à chaque
fois nous nous adaptons aux
particularités de l'événement par
exemple la provenance du public mais
aussi aux circonstances de l'événement
les flux de passagers habituels les
travaux ou encore les éventuels
mouvements sociaux s'agissant du
dispositif du 28 mai le 28 mai dernier
80000 spectateurs étaient attendus dont
une grande partie y était comme
habituellement acheminés en transport en
commun par les lignes b et d du rer mais
également par les lignes 12 et 13 du
métro cet événement comporte deux
éléments de complexité d'une part les
provenances multiples des spectateurs
anglais et notamment de la panne zone
depuis le cours de vincennes d'autre
part une grève ratp sur la ligne b que
nous qu'aux exploitants pour cet
événement nous avons dû mettre en place
un dispositif à la fois habituel par son
ampleur est inédit dans ses modalités un
dispositif habituel car comme à chaque
événement de cette nature un dispositif
spécifique est mis en oeuvre sous
l'autorité des pouvoirs publics en
présence des organisateurs la fédération
française de football où l'uefa par
exemple du stade de france
d'ile-de-france mobilité de la ratp de
transiger c'est d'ozil un dispositif
inédit en raison de la grève de la ratp
sur la ligne b annoncé dès le 23 mai qui
a eu pour conséquence la suspension de
l'interconnexion gare du nord et donc
l'obligation pour les voyageurs de
changer de train dans cette gare
cette grève nous a conduit à adapter
avec la ratp notre offre de transport en
proposant d' orienter prioritairement
les voyageurs vers la ligne d ce choix
est aussi motivée par la prise en compte
de la localisation de la fan zone cours
de vincennes qui nous a conduit à
renforcer cette même ligne d à ce qu'il
y ait d'un passage via la gare de lyon
le choix du plan de transport adapté a
été pris entre opérateurs de transport
concentré concerter avec la france
mobilité partagée en réunion présidée
par les autorités dès le 25 mai et
communiquer publiquement le 26 mai
l'information voyageurs sur le plan de
transport invitant à utiliser
de préférence la ligne d a été fait de
façon renforcée sur tous les supports
réseaux sociaux annonces sonores etc dès
le jeudi 26 mai suite à la réunion de la
veille
s'agissant de l'offre de transport
concernant l'offre de transport comme
pour tout événement au stade de france à
jauge pleine de 80000 spectateurs nous
avons assuré un plan de transport
spécifique à partir de hache moins trois
heures avant le match et jusqu'à 1h35 du
matin horaires du dernier train de
retour à chaque événement ayant lieu au
stade de france un représentant de sncf
est présent dans le centre de
commandement du stade de france on
appelle presser haut ils assurent le
lien en temps réel avec notre groupe et
les autorités et notre salle de crise
régional est également active et toute
la journée du 28 mai nous avons mis en
place un dispositif d'information
renforcé avec plus d'une centaine
d'effectifs supplémentaires pour
orienter les flux dans les grandes gares
concernées sur les quais et les parvis
permettez moi à présent de revenir sur
le détail du dispositif mis en place le
soir du 28 mai le matériel roulant tout
d'abord le matériel roulant était
utilisé en unités multiples ce qui veut
dire deux rames jointives soit une
capacité par trains du rer b 2700 places
et pour le rrd de 2400 places nous avons
assuré un plan de transport sur leur
herbe est partie nord malgré l'
interconnexion suspendue avec six trains
supplémentaires à l'aller en plus des
dix trains prévus par heure et huit
trains supplémentaires au retour en plus
des huit trains prévus vers paris des
trains supplémentaires par rapport à un
soir d'événements au stade de france ont
également été mises en circulation sur
les lignes du rer d compte tenu du
report vers le erreurs des attendus avec
trois trains supplémentaires à l'aller
en plus des huit trains prévus par heure
et dix trains supplémentaires au retour
en plus des deux trains prévus par heure
les rames supplémentaires ont été mises
en circulation en fonction de l'arrivée
des flux de voyageurs
suite à l'affluence de voyageurs
souhaitant revenir à paris pendant le
match le dispositif d'accueil en gare de
la plaine stade de france un rer b a été
remise en place après la fin de la
première mi-temps à
22h52 le dispositif de prolongation qui
consiste à retarder d'environ une heure
les navettes prévues sur les lignes b et
d a été déclenché et compte tenu de
l'heure tardive de la fin de l'événement
qui a permis que le dernier train parte
de l'as de la plaine stade de france
vers 1h35 pour la première fois
l'aéroport charles de gaulle depuis
paris nord a été desservie par quatre
rames navette à l'issue du match
s'agissant du comptage le dispositif a
ainsi permis d'acheminer le soir du
match trente sept mille spectateurs par
le rrd six mille deux cents spectateurs
par leur herbe et et par comparaison
dans ce type d'événement le rer b
achemine habituellement en moyenne 21
mille six cents personnes et le rer d
9600 nous avons donc transporté au total
près de 40 % de voyageurs
supplémentaires par rapport à l'habitude
43 1200 versus 31200 je précise que les
comptages auquel nous procédons est
effectué manuellement uniquement l'aller
par des agents affectés à cette mission
dans nos gares s'agissant des incidents
sur le plan de la sûreté il n'y a pas eu
d'incident majeur à l'intérieur des
emprises sncf lors de cette soirée à
l'exception de quelques événements
notamment d'une rixe d'après match en
gare de saint denis avec un supporters
anglais blessé nous avons constaté en
revanche de nombreux faits de
délinquance aux abords de nos emprises
lors de l'après match et du retour des
voyageurs vers nos gars de la plaine
saint-denis contenu de l'événement une
centaine d'agents de sûreté sncf a été
engagée sur notre réseau
enfin pour conclure aux yeux du
transporteur que nous sommes le
dispositif de transport a été adaptée
aux besoins de cet événement et s'est
déroulée dans de bonnes conditions sans
congestion anormale cela tient à la fois
aux dispositifs d'information tant en
nombre qu'en positionnement à la bonne
performance de la production du rer b et
pour le retour à la bonne coordination
pour l'envoi des rames en fonction des
flux de supporters sur le rer b pour
conclure avant de répondre avec sylvie
charles à vos questions je souhaiterais
simplement
souligner la mobilisation et le
professionnalisme de toutes les équipes
de transilien en lien avec nos collègues
de la ratp pour réaliser ce plan de
transport pour prolonger la circulation
des trains jusqu'à une heure tardive et
pour assurer l'information des voyageurs
je vous remercie merci monsieur présent
peut-être tout de suite une question
avez vous conservé des images
des lieux qui sont sous votre
responsabilité ou pas
laissez moi j'en ai faire de manière
habituelle les images sur la
vidéosurveillance qui sont dans les
gares aux abords immédiats sont
conservés 72 heures pour des raisons de
stockage dans le cas précis et
d'ailleurs avec un léger décalage comme
nous avons eu un incident en garde saint
denis et souvent saint denis et stade de
france saint-denis sont confondus
la sûreté ferroviaire bloqués comme la
loi l'y autorise puisqu'on peut les
conserver jusqu'à 30 jours
et puis après le vendredi 1er juin dans
l'après-midi la même sûreté ferroviaire
a reçu un appel je crois de la brigade
territoriale des transports demandant de
bloquer les images donc une partie avait
commencé à être effacées notamment à la
plaine saint denis mais pas tous et donc
on a conservé comme la loi nous permet
les images et nous avons reçus des
réquisitions en deux temps vendredi
dernier c'était hier le 10 juin
si pour ces précisions m'a donc des
conservations partielle des images et
une réquisition arrivé la semaine
dernière en réalité si je mets ça dans
le temps au moment où nous même avoué
après les auditions qui ont été les
nôtres jeudi dernier on nous avait dit
que
le stade de france n'avait conservé que
l'image merci à ce stade merci beaucoup
monsieur martin dont la ratp vous avez
la parole oui messieurs et présente
commission de l'âme et messieurs
sénatrice on tient à vous remercier pour
votre invitation et dans le cadre des
auditions vous venez pour faire la
lumière ce qui s'est passé ce samedi 28
mai on va vous apporter l'éclairage
puisque comme vous l'avez dit le
président de l'atp sncf en tant
qu'opérateur transports ont un rôle
essentiel dans la gestion des grands
événements
hollande répond aux questions 62 points
christoph aebischer a expliqué que
comment elle fonctionne et de la linde
et donc sur la partie sud la situation
normale de la ligne b et que ces lignes
qui est interconnecté c'est à dire que
les trains continuent et les voyageurs
n'ont pas de rupture de charge voire un
terreau opérer et cette spécificité a
conduit ratp sncf à travailler ensemble
au sein d'une structure commune dédiée à
la ligne la direction dit unifiée et ce
qui nous permet de mieux collaborer
étroitement l'organisation notamment des
grands événements
pour le préparer l'événement
on a eu des réunions fréquentes depuis
mars avec les organisateurs
lefa la fff la préfecture de police
différents acteurs transport
progressivement afin d'affiner
d'organiser des systèmes
on a effectivement communiquer
l'ensemble toutes les parties prenantes
dont la fédération française de football
l'information sur la grève et notamment
le plan de transport comme ça a été dit
il ya une dépêche afp du 26
26 je mets qui indique clairement que la
ratp invite les voyageurs à utiliser
prioritairement la ligne d c'était bien
les consignes qui avait été envoyé par
mail il confirmait à l'uefa la fff et la
prison de police avec qui on a collaboré
ensemble
pour l'air atp on avait un triple triple
problématique nous on devait bien sûr
acheminer l'ensemble des voyageurs un
stade de france via la ligne 13 un petit
peu la ligne 12 la ligne b on avait
aussi toute la gestion des flux autour
de la fan zone est rapatrié d'un surnom
de voyageurs qui avaient des anglais
supporter anglais y avait des mines un
fan zone
et un certain nombre d'entre eux
voulaient parce qu'il a des billets
voulait monter au stade de france donc
l'organisation du transfert vers le
stade de france et puis bien sûr la
gestion de la grève afin de limiter au
maximum l'impact sur l'acheminement des
supporters
donc son dispositif a été validée dès le
24 mai et a été transmis communiqué et
notamment le fait qu' il y aura une
rupture interconnexion sur lignes b et
la rupture d'interconnexion sur la ligne
b fait qu'un voyageur arrive en gare
souterraine de la ligne b nord il va
remonter aux deux niveaux pour aller
prendre un train à la gare de surface ce
qui est un itinéraire peu facile et
encore plus pour des étudiants étrangers
dont l'habitué des lieux
alors que en face ce qui peut expliquer
un peu d'évasion 10 voyages réalisés
alors qu'en face il est trés les trains
de la ligne d qui arrive qu'ils vont
directement
au stade de france qui fait que des
trains de la ligne b qui venaient du sud
car ils gardent une horde conduit par
ratp
les voyageurs étaient choisis sert pour
leur itinéraire ou ligne 2 ou ligue b
dans le cas de la préparation du match
on a eu aussi des réunions organisées
par la délégation interministérielle aux
grands événements sportifs la djs
et on a fait une réunion de terrain le
vendredi 27 mai à 10 heures sous l'égide
du directeur de la sous-direction de la
police régionale des transports la
presse de police afin d' organiser
l'acheminement des flux de la fan zone
vers le stade de france donc l accès
entre la privilégier la ligne à quel
accès on va prendre la ligne à que
arrivé à gare de lyon une partie des
voyageurs seraient dirigés vers linde et
et l'équipe de la préfet de police ont
mis des agents de sécurité de police en
plus de nos agents de sécurité femme est
canalisé cas châtelet les halles il
prenait de la ligne b
en ce qui concerne l'exploitation des
réseaux donc des renforts d'offres ont
été mis en place donc on a fait pendant
la période de montée on faisait 80 % des
trams les ruptures de charge il a été
mis en place les six trains
supplémentaires qui ont été direct qui
sont les navettes qu'on met à la con
mais en plus proche mines et des
voyageurs et qui repartent le soir pour
faire les navettes supplémentaires de
retour
s'il avait transmis entre 19h30 et 20h30
pour le métro on a mis 19 trains
supplémentaires pour la ligne 13 pour
l'acheminement salles de france et on a
renforcé 29 trains sur ligue 2 4 6 9 et
12 notamment pour la desserte des fans
zone
on a aussi dans le plan mobilisé 600
agents dont trois en gestation et 300
prestataires et 150 agents de sécurité
qu'il est placé à châtelet gare de lyon
nation et la station ligne 13 porte de
saint denis
concernant la coordination de la
prévision police le jour l'événement
l'arrêté pl était présente au centre de
coordination opérationnel la sécurité le
projet de police si ces os et les
stations les plus critiques étaient sous
couverture vidéo constante depuis le
cceo spp qui accueillait un
correspondant sncf également de ces
emprises
concernant donc la communication avec la
pp puisque interrogés et surtout la
fédération française de football donc la
réunion du 24 mai après clairement
préciser les choses clairement précisé
le plan de transport clairement indiqué
qu on allait reporter une partie des
flux la libé vers la ligne d
au cours cette réunion de la fédération
française de football a demandé qu' on
indique des messages pour supporter
anglais ce qu'on a fait en indiquant qu'
supporters anglais prenez la ligne b & b
et on a fait des misères trois espagnols
qui devait prendre la ligne 13 puisque
affaires de france de football a demandé
de dissocier des flux si on m'a fait
très était à 8
pour
les messages sonores aussi
voyant ça c'est le traquent les flyers
ski qui montre que ses bd c'était écrit
s'était affichée on a les affiches que
demander la sphère axa france de
football la mise en espace qui était
clairement bd et puis
direction
le 27 mai donc concernant le plan de
transport et l'impact de
l'interconnexion donc on a fait un point
de situation à des opérations française
de football pour indiquer le plan bien
entendu on n'avait pas d'idée claire sur
le flux de report de la mb valine des
comme ça et il y ait plus de voyageurs
souligne décennies des
mets et puis le samedi 28 mai important
nous avons notre directrice a permis au
général qui supérieur zone des réseaux a
eu au moins six 6 appels téléphoniques
elle peut correspondre la fédération
française de football
les changements récents l'évacuation de
la fan zone aux nations quelle est la
situation sur nos réseaux la gestion des
flux qui à partir de 21h de deux coups
de fil qui abordait le problème de la
prolongation du dispositif opérationnel
puisque comme le match aller du retard
on est obligé de décaler du nord les
fins de service les trains et prolonger
le service de tous nos agents
donc on considère que les échanges avec
les organisateurs toutes les parties
prenantes ont été constants en avant
pendant et après l'événement
j'oserais même dire aussi que nous avons
reçu un mail le 1er juin la fédération
française de football qui ce fait je
voulais vous remercier pour tous les
échanges ces deux dernières semaines
nos conversations récentes ce vote vécu
et tendances interne transport samedi 28
mai
qui fait qu'on était un peu surpris des
déclarations
la fédération française de football
concernant la grève mais sa gestion
alors on cache pas que l'impact de la
grève et la rupture interconnexion a
forcément perturbé
l'organisation et elle nous a forcés à
nous adapter comme allez christophe
aniche est la gestion des flux et donc
le report un peu sur les lignes d et
peut aussi on arrive constaté un plus
grand nombre de voyageurs souligne 13
et on a fait une communication et
d'information région adapté
tiens aussi à dire que leur offre ces
mouvements de grève aussi on a un plan
de mobilisation de toutes les ressources
internes qui sont pas que des
conducteurs du rer que l'on mobilise
nous agents qualifiés formés qui sont
capables de ça et on zappe on a engagé
tous les moyens qu'on avait disponibles
et formés sur pour la conduite des
trains rer comme vous fait classiquement
sur chacune des greffes
se déroulait la soirée donc on a eu un
flux important de supporters ont des
parts de la fan zone donations entre 17h
et 18h30 mais qui s'est passé dans le
calme pour nous
les trains du rer a ont bien absorbé la
charge ce départ des flux la répartition
entre les trains la ligne d la ligne b à
châtelet n'a pas montré de surcharge
importante
pour les comptages donc soline 13 on a
entre 16h et 21h on a compté trente six
mille voyageurs qui arrivait au stade de
france
les contacts se font comme la sncf c'est
sont deux agents au comptage manuel mais
qui sont un peu habitués qu'ils sont des
comptages qu'on considérera 5% vrai call
it à 1 % d'erreurs parce c'est un
comptage manuel donc
pour la ligne b donc on a une ou dix
mille 500 voyageurs qui ont pris la
ligne b qui sont arrivés gare du nord
mais après je après la ligne b o
connor
acheminer 6200 personnes à saint denis
la raison des flux a été maîtrisé on a
aussi à la fin du match à la fois la fan
zone mais aussi pour la ligne 13 un
dispositif assez rodée de stop and go
avec les forces de sécurité qui évite la
thrombose dans nos espaces qui fondent
et retenue en amont de l'entrée dans nos
réseaux et donc on n'a pas à signaler le
moindre incident ça s'est bien passé à
la sortie de la fan zone et ça s'est
bien passé aussi
la sortie vers la ligne 13 après le
match on a pu avoir une bonne régulation
pour l'un d'exploitation on a eu aucun
incident technique qui n'a pas été les
seules pertes critique parce que on
avait en prévision adapter le plan
transport mais il nous arrive parfois en
temps réel en fonction des incidents est
en capacité et en dessous d'un contrat
de collaboration d'adapter l'offre s'il
y avait un incident sur une ligne par
rapport à une autre
la fréquentation était forte pour nous
une ingénieure aucun sinon et des
voyageurs on considère tous âges ont été
acheminés sans difficulté valgeir la
station d'arrivée à la question nous
avons pas eu d'incident ni d'agression
sur nos espaces
concernant les images iso surveillance
c'est comme si licha nous elles sont
stockées sous 72 heures c'est dans le
sens écrasé n'ayant pas eu d'incident on
n'a pas fait
mesure de les stocker et on n'a pas une
réquisition sauf le vendredi
[Musique]
sissoko par la faune merci madame et
messieurs on va commencer par une série
d question en essayant de revenir sur un
certain nombre de deux points que vous
nous avez indiqué dans vos propos
liminaire si vous permettez je vais
commencer par l'impact de la de la grève
qu'on comprenne bien l'enchaînement des
décisions et des adaptations rendue
nécessaire par cette annonce de grève
donc annonces de grève j - 4 réunion le
25 mai dans lequel vous décider
collectivement réunion à la préfecture
de police dans lequel vous décidez en
présence de la fédération française de
football dans lequel vous décidé
d'orienter
les spectateurs vers la ligne d au
détriment de la ligne b puisque la ligne
b et
fait l'objet d'une dune d'une grève
je vois ma première question bon ils
sont que la grève a été moins suivie
qu'on ne pouvait le penser que vous
pouvez le penser à l'origine puisqu'on
annonce
4 trains sur 5 finalement sur la ligne b
à partir de 17h 3 sur 4 avant
j'imagine qu'au moment où vous prenez la
décision le 25 de réorienter
majoritairement les l'espé les usagers
vers la ligne d vous attendiez un taux
de grève plus important est ce que le
fait que cette grève a été finalement
moins suivi ne vous a pas amené à
rééquilibrer davantage les flux entre
les deux lignes et à quel moment
avez-vous su que cette grève serait
finalement moins suivie
cette grève a été fortement suivie
donc je vais les chiffres des quatre
trains sur 5 qui me fait dire qu'elle a
été moins suivie voilà donc j'ai au
direct il ya beaucoup de conducteurs qui
tend mouvement de grève sur qui ont
déclaré des moments se mettre en grève
il faut savoir que d'après la loi sur la
déclaration on a la connaissance des
grévistes 48 heures avant et qu'ils ont
encore 24 heures pour changer d'avis
modifier la durée de la grève donc
on n'a pas pu donner le plan avant le 26
simplement au vu de nom de grévistes on
a essayé de mobiliser l'ensemble des
autres agents d'entreprises qualifiées
l'encadrement essentiellement pour
pouvoir conduire les trains et pour voir
sur un minimum de services mais l'offre
de transport qui a été réalisé avec la
sncf c'est une offre qui est en forte
réduction et la rupture d'interconnexion
à permet aussi d'économiser des moyens
pour pouvoir acheminer un minimum de
train vers la gare du nord donc voila et
navettes de trains supplémentaires ont
été tous assurés par la sncf cela dit
ratp sur linde et si tu permets finition
de ferme était président je vais juste
pour compléter deux semaines donc
l'infrastructure et ratp jusqu'à gare du
nord et les sncf réseau à partir de gare
du nord
par contre en tant qu'exploitant en tant
que transporteur
nouco exploitons la ligne et nos
conducteurs ratp comme sncf en temps
normal du bout en bout de la ligne quand
il ya beaucoup de grévistes qu'on ne
peut être
qu'on ne sait comme l'a dit philippe
martin que 48 heures avant la vue les
rumeurs et tous à un moment on s'est dit
qu'ils allaient y avoir beaucoup de
grévistes
et c'est à ce moment là qu'on prend
l'option de supprimer l'interconnexion
pourquoi parce que la ratp comme de son
côté la sncf met tout particulièrement
la ratp tous les encadrants conduisent
mais ils ne conduisent que sur la partie
infrastructure ratp parce que pour
conduire sur les deux infrastructures
pour le coup c'est un métier les
signalisations sont pas les mêmes et
donc il faut vraiment de pratique et
très souvent c'est ce qui nous conduit à
faire ce qu'on appelle rompre l'
interconnexion à ce moment là les trains
du sud vont jusqu'à gare du nord où il
se retourne
et nous nous prenons le relais côté sncf
en gare du nord surface de manière à
permettre à la ratp se retourner sur les
infrastructures
d'où la cette fameuse rupture
d'interconnexion et c'est ce qui nous a
permis de faire ce qu'on fait d'habitude
c'est ce qu'on appelle une b10 dit tu
râles puisqu'il faut transporter les
supporters mais il faut aussi quand même
continuer à transporter tous les
voyageurs du quotidien donc on a fait
dix trains leur ratp venant du sud
s'arrête en gare du nord et nous prenant
le relais en surface à cela et pour
offrir un maximum de capacité par
rapport à l'événement stade de france
nous avons ajouté quelques train
traversant qui à l'aller sont partie de
denfert rochereau
pour aller jusqu'à la plaine stade de
france ces trains donc pour le coup eux
interconnecté ont été faits par des
conducteurs sncf
qui sont allés chercher les trains à
denfert rochereau les ont amenés jusqu'à
la plaine saint denis voilà exactement
le dispositif qui a été mis en place et
comme l'a dit mon collègue philippe
martin dans la mesure où si vous arrivez
du sud par l'abbé vous arrivait en gare
souterraine vous vous arrêtez gare du
nord puisque ces trains s'arrêter là
c'est plus facile si votre destination
finale est d'aller au stade de france
c'est plus facile de traverser le quai
pour prendre le rer d que de monter de
niveau dans la gare du nord pour aller
prendre la suite du rer b en gare de
surface
sajan torres est bien mais après c'est
une question de réorientation des des
spectateurs auriez pu re orienter
davantage
vous avez pu éventuellement orienté vers
le but alors pour bien comprendre parce
que c'est vous c'est
l'interconnexion en fallait les liens
sont complexes à comprendre de
l'extérieur je posais la question
autrement est ce que le jour du match et
l'après midi du match est-ce que la
ligne b les trains de la ligne b était
plein ou est ce qu aurait une
possibilité
compte tenu finalement du nombre de
trains sur la ligne b de les remplir
davantage
j'ai pas exactement la question alors il
n'y a pas que les supporters il ya aussi
les laïcs mais dans le quotidien les
touristes tout ça donc les trains
étaient
plats mais je vous ai dit n'y a pas eu
de surcharge signalé j'ai pas les
éléments
c'est un point important
de savoir si vous aviez pu utiliser
davantage la ligne b le jour du match
parce que tout le problème des gestion
des flux de spectateurs vous le savez ça
a été un nombre important et vos
chiffres le montrent de spectateurs qui
sont arrivés sur la guerre rer d avec
tous les effets d'engorgement sur les
points de filtrage moi ma question c'est
est-ce que compte tenu finalement des
informations j'entends bien que vous ne
pouviez pas le savoir quatre jours avant
mais la veille est ce qu'il y avait
possibilité ce jour-là de transporter
davantage
d'utilisateurs afin que les spectateurs
d'utilisateurs sur la ligne b je peux
pas vous répondre précisément ce que
doivent signaler aussi c'est que on a
quelqu'un à ses os il y avait les gens
qui sait si le stade de france on a les
contacts avec la fff à aucun moment on a
eu la moindre alerte de quiconque cas un
problème sur la ligne d est sorti des
voyageurs de la ligne d personne ne nous
a dit parce qu on aurait pu
éventuellement réorienter en temps réel
mais personne nous alerter qui va
difficulté vous auriez pu vous adapter
et éventuellement si on vous avait
informé qu'ils avaient la même
nom mais nous on aurait pu nous adapter
si on nous avait demandé de dévier des
flux on va en gros tenir des trains
c'est des choses qu auxerre peut faire
bas comme les faucons faut qu'on nous
prévienne carnet de l'information alors
qu'est ce qui s'est dit exactement le 25
et le 27 sur la question de l'arrivée
des usagers ou gare rer d vous saviez
puisque c'étaient les orientations
retenues d'orienter davantage les
usagers sur le rer d qu'est ce qui se
dit entre la sortie du rer et les points
de filtrage parce que ce qui frappe tout
le monde quand on regarde le nombre de
points de filtrage où il y en avait vous
corriger si je me trompe 20 à la sortie
du rer b et 10 seulement pour des
raisons physiques si je comprends bien
géographique à la à la sortie du rer d
est ce qu'au moment où on se dit on va
les orienter davantage sur la rd il ya
eu des interrogations jeu
en deux vous aimez des participants
réunion celle du 25 et du 27 décembre
que la fédération française de football
n'était pas à la réunion du 27 vous nous
confirmer et ce qui s'est dit il faut
qu'on mette des zones de délestage pour
que à la sortie du rer d une partie des
spectateurs se rendent sur les points de
filtrage du rer b
un rien du 27
la fff n'était pas ce qui était une
réunion de sécurité avec la prévision de
police essentiellement voilà on les
informer des décisions juste après et
l'orientation de la ligne d voilà après
nous quand les voyageurs ce soit
l'organisation des filtrages
organisation l'accueil les mesures les
canalisations l'aiguillage parce qu'il
peut y avoir aussi des aiguillages
différents caps est organisé depuis les
sorties des stations et gares je n'ai
pas d'éléments précis et sa place à
l'histoire évoqué là dessus ça a été
évoqué le fait de dire il ya trois fois
et demi plus de spectateurs face à une
sélectif qui arrivent par la rd donc
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ces gens une fois
qu'ils sortent de la station du rer d et
on les oriente vers quel point de
filtrage est ce que je comprends bien
que votre responsabilité s'arrête arrivé
en gare mais comme vous avez participé à
ces réunions on se permet de vous poser
la question est ce que ça a été évoqué
qu'est ce qui se passe pour les
spectateurs entre la sortie gare rer d
et les points de filtrage
dans la connaissance à prêter vos crimes
ça n'a pas été évoquée 22 25 27 et vous
dites également que pendant le l'après
midi du du match il n'y a pas eu de
liaison sur ce point entre fédération
française de football et vous pour dire
non mais on a eu six nous
personnellement atp mais si contact
téléphonique correspondant reste chef
qui était là depuis 15 jours qu'il a
même remercié comme je voulais dit tout
à l'heure et pour lequel on lui a donné
les infos la fan zone la gestion des
flux la situation sur les réseaux qui
avait pas prenez surchargé
et le soir la prolongation du service
mais à aucun moment il nous a indiqué le
moindre des moins de difficultés
d'accord ils devaient pas remonté à ce
niveau si ça vous avait été indiqué vous
auriez pu éventuellement réorienter
entre d et b 1 c'est bien ce qu'on
comprend oui si la préfecture de police
parce que c'est aussi un point de
sécurité police et ordinateurs nous on
dit fait prenez des mesures on serait
concerté sncf a rappelé les mesures
adaptées avec un délai de neuf bien sûr
d'accord j'ai une dernière question
avant de la passer de transmettre la
parole avec à mes collègues sur les
chiffres c'est un autre sujet un autre
point mais vous avez que les chiffres
que vous avez fournis ont été repris à
la fois par le préfet de police dans sa
note du lendemain du dimanche et puis le
ministre de l'intérieur
par la suite dans la communication
gouvernementale
moi j'ai
deux questions à vous poser sur ces
chiffres d'abord est ce que vous
confirmez bien les chiffres que vous
avez indiqué parce qu'on sent du côté du
gouvernement et notamment dans le
no tamment de d2 préfet l'allemand et
cadeaux qu'ils reviennent un peu sur le
chiffre est finalement c'est moins
important que ça le nombre de
spectateurs qui sont venus sans billet
ou avec des faux billets est ce que vous
confirmez bien vos chiffres et pourriez
vous nous expliquez vous l'avez dit un
petit peu l'un et l'autre comptage
manuel sert deux personnes à la à la
sortie des gars qui font un comptage
n'avait précisé que c'était des gens
expérimentés qui savait faire quelle est
la fiabilité de ces chiffres je vous ai
interrompu tout à l'heure pour vous
précisez bien sûr la marge d'erreur pour
vous la marge d'erreur est de 5% pas
plus c'est à dire que vous nous dites il
ya bien eu 110 milles gens qui ont
utilisé les
les deux les différentes lignes d'accès
y compris la ligne 13 ce jour là et donc
l'estimation des 30 à 40000
spectateurs en plus elle peut tout à
fait être sorties de vos chiffres c'est
bien c'est bien
nous on peut donner que les chiffres de
nous ramener ce chiffre à une bd 10500
sont six en partie du sud est qui arrive
à gare du nord et on a des 36000 pour
rappel 16h 21h pour la ligne 13 voulait
confirmer oui marché c'est % révise
sagna pas ce que l'on parle pas des les
10500 c'est ce qui arriva hier du nord
côté transilien
on compte b&d à l'arrivée pour le stade
de france c'est à dire on compte ça pour
la dea stade de france saint-denis et
pour la baie à la plaine stade de france
à la sortie du rer b la plaine stade de
france nous avons compté 6200 voilà donc
il ya de l'évaporation si je perds mais
je m'appelle je peux me permettre
l'expression mais c'est assez logique
parce que on a des tout le monde ne va
pas ne va pas au stade de france
donc c'est 6200 pour l'abbé donc à peu
près le tiers de ce qu'on transporte
habituellement par l'abbé et à stade de
france saint-denis on en a compté plus
de 35000 donc plus de trois fois ce
qu'on a habituellement habituellement
sur l'année
merci j'ai passé la parole avec mes
collègues on commença par david
assouline
oui merci de vos précisions moi j'ai les
trois questions
vaz
[Musique]
j'ai trois questions très précises
qui font l'objet de nos interrogations
je crois que le ministre et vous avez un
peu confirmé je ne sais plus qui d'entre
vous nous a dit pour s pour
démontrer quelque part qu' il y avait eu
30 à 40000 personnes de plus qui étaient
venus sans billet ou
où elle des faux billets au dos dans les
entourages du stade de france que la
preuve c'est qu'il ya eu un
demande pour les faire revenir avant la
fin du match et que les flux était très
important de retour
vous vous dites et je l'avais déjà
entendu que les à 22h50 que cette
décision a été prise d'envoyer
des voitures supplémentaires je trouve
la chose un peu étrange parce qu'en
réalité le match devait se terminer à
22h50
donc c'était déjà installé le dispositif
pour faire revenir
les dizaines de milliers de personnes
qui finissait le match
oui ce que je veux dire
normalement le match devait finir à
22h56 avait pas eu ce retard donc le
dispositif était prêt pour ramener tous
les spectateurs qui étaient venus au
stade je ne comprends pas pourquoi il a
fallu à 22h50 prévoir un dispositif
supplémentaire pour ramener ces trente
mille personnes en fait il est il
existait c'est pas une preuve
qu'avance le ministre que de dire la
preuve qu'il y avait 3000 personnes à
ramener c'est qu'on a dû réquisitionner
des voitures bon d'être compliqué mais
c'est quand même précis par rapport à
l'affirmation de
ensuite sur les images j'aimerais bien
comprendre le processus ce qui nous
étonne le plus dans l'histoire c'est que
tout le monde avait des images enfin
tous les opérateurs et serra et ceux qui
étaient dans la salle de commandes de pc
de sécurité étaient très diverses on
n'arrive pas à comprendre comment dans
une chaîne aussi un port tout d'acteurs
avec leurs collaborateurs avec les
ministres et tout ça n'est pas eu en
même en visionnant ces images on dirait
le réflexe de dire on conserve parce que
ça a un intérêt vu des incidents
voit la scène celle des preuves que le
témoin de cela c'est à dire que en les
ayant conservé vous vous montrez du
doigt presque aujourd'hui pourquoi les
autres n'ont pas fait c'est à dire que
bien entendu la première responsable
c'est ce qu'ils doivent réquisitionnés
parce que les enquêtes et tout mais les
opérateurs eux mêmes je suis étonné que
le stade de france ne se soit pas dit la
même chose que vous
sncf
voire même vous vous dites il n'y a pas
eu d'incident ton qu'on ne conserve pas
m'enfin bon et
comment vous avez pris cette décision
parce qu'on peut se dire que chez les
autres il ya eu les mêmes réflexions
quelqu'un a dû dire pourquoi on les
garde pas et quelqu'un a dit ben on les
garde pas je pense que dans toutes les
entités quelqu'un a dit au moins est ce
qu'on les garde on les garde pas assez
posé la question c'est pas pareil de les
laisser s'écraser
comme ça parce que personne n'a eu
l'idée que une réflexion quelqu'un dit
est ce qu'on les garde et quelqu'un dit
on les garde pas on ne le demande pas
donc j'aimerais
savoir comment à la sncf cette décision
a été prise de les garder avec quelles
qu'elles
quelles réflexions
jeu
si j'ai bien compris parce que là c'est
quand même
bizarre parce que je vois pas l'intérêt
mais enfin bon j'ai peut-être de se
défausser
ce que vous nous dites démens
complètement quelque chose de très
formelle que nous a dit de la fff en en
audition puisqu'il 10e que
vous avez été alertés et il ya eu des
conversations
au moment où les filtrages était engorgé
sur le fait que
[Musique]
ben que tous venaient vers le rer n'est
que n'ont jamais pu en amont
pour réorienter leur filtrage qui était
plus important à la sortie du rer b
vous nous dites en amants ils étaient
alertés qu'il y avait cette
réorientation nettement en amont et vous
nous dites que même pendant cet
engorgement à aucun moment dans les
conversations si conversation ils vous
ont alerté de la chose pour pouvoir
remettre en place le dispositif c'est
totalement en contradiction avec un
témoignage ici de la fff donc vous nous
confirmer tout ce que vous venez nous
dire la fff ne nous a pas dit la réalité
des choses à ce moment là je passe la
parole à michel injuste pour prolonger
la question de débit des sunu fait
référence à des discussions
fff ratp vous êtes les uns et les autres
présents aux différents postes de
commandement celui de la préfecture de
police et celui du stade de france là il
ya tout le monde autour de la table
et vous voyez les uns et les autres les
points d'engorgement j'imagine que ça se
constate dans les pc et ça ça réagit
dans les pc
permet de prolonger la question je veux
faire un potager entre la question est
là plus loin selon vous quelle autorité
qui aurait dû dire à un moment vous dire
un moment vous faire dire attendez on
change de paradigme
on change d'organisation parce qu'on
constate tel ou tel événement qui est
l'autorité qui aurait dû
prononcer cet ordre vous laisser
répondre à cette série de questions
parce que et après je passerai la parole
à michel savin parce que là il ya quand
même des points importants dans notre
compréhension de ce qui s'est passé
non je puisse sur les différents points
par rapport à l'affluence en milieu de
match en effet c'est rarissime
donc il était 22 heures 22h50 52 avec
oui mais là on savait que c'était pas la
fin du match puisque le début du match
avait été retardée depuis quand même
société connue donc on savait depuis
déjà plusieurs heures que la fin du
match
enfin ça fait quand même nous avons une
capacité d'adaptation qui est quand même
à la demi-heure voire au quart d'heure
de ces soirs de matches donc on savait
que le match ne se termineraient pas à
l'heure à l'heure prévue
par contre en effet en a vu du monde
arrivé et ce qu'on a constaté face qui
nous a été dit et qui paraissait c'était
des gens sans billet qui du coup
n'arrivant pas à rentrer dans le stade
repartait repartis vers paris et donc on
arrête quand on dit qu'on a remis le
dispositif en place on vise en fait le
dispositif dans la gare de la plaine
stade de france où on a du personnel
agents propre ou sous traitance qui
oriente oriente les des voyageurs vers
vers le bon qu'est donc voilà ce qui
s'est passé à 22h à peu près à 22h45
on
ne compte pas parce qu'on réagit on
remet surtout vite le dispositif en
place
donc les premiers trains d'ailleurs ont
été un peu perturbée puisque on mettait
des trains à quai et avait des
spectateurs qui avaient à la fois envie
d'entrer mais qui quand même attendait
de voir
smartphone à l'appui comment se
passaient le match donc il ya eu un
début un peu chaotique où on a fait
partir du coût des trains qui étaient
pas très remplie et puis petit à petit
ces personnes là sont rentrés sont
rentrés dans les trains voilà ce qui ce
qui a été donné pour répondre sur la
vidéosurveillance a comme nous nous
avions eu des petits incidents en tout
cas à garde saint denis ça a conduit la
sûreté ferroviaire a
bloqué bloquer les images c'est juste
mais c'est parce que pour le reste
et comme l'a dit philippe martin
globalement autant à saint denis on a eu
un incident avec un supporters qui
manifestement avait été blessé il ya une
rixe est il sorti du train autant sur le
reste nous n'avons eu aucun incident et
d'ailleurs toutes les vidéos
surveillance à bord des rames elles ont
été ont été effacés les seules choses
nous qui nous reste c'est les vidéos de
surveillance qui ont été bloqués en gare
de saint denis
de la plaine saint denis et saint denis
stade de france est encore dans ses deux
derniers regards l'effacement avait
commencé mais même finir juste une
précision donc c'est naturel dans une
institution vous nous donner la raison
s'il ya des un style dans au stade de
france sur l'esplanade cetera de dire
aux conserves parce que vous en avez
vous conservé
il y en a eu pour le témoin à terre et
que vous êtes nombreux à vouloir
intervenir donc chaque chacun reprend
pas la parole comme ça on laisse
répondre
outre micro madame nos vidéosurveillance
ne filme que nos emprises nous filmons
parce qu' à l'extérieur et donc nous les
conservons quand un incident est remonté
par un agent garbia sa hiérarchie qu'il
ya eu un incident soit à bord d'une rame
soit en règle générale à la descente à
la descente du train c'est avant tout ce
genre d'incidents qui fait qu'on va
conserver
bon bon pour les vidéos c'est pareil
demain que l'emprise locale concernant
le secteur du stade de france il y avait
que la un terreau de la ligne 13 la
station porte de paris donc on avait pas
de caméra sur ce qui s'est passé aux
alentours du stade donc faute
d'incidents n'apparaît qui suis né et
puis faute aux conditions formelles on
n'a pas eu
pour la fédération française de football
doit changer et oui il était au courant
qu'on allait reporter voyageant la ligne
des cités dans les dépêches les
communications publiques les affichettes
les flyers ça c'était indiquer
clairement voilà ce que ce qui ne
pouvait pas anticiper c'est elle la
nature du flux non plus on pouvait pas
savoir quelle part de flux est reporté
de la b vers la d ça il peut rien
peut-être eu plus de report qui n'avait
estimé serbe peut le comprendre donc je
le maintiens
après je maintien que lors du 28 on a eu
aucune alerte de quiconque
du stade de france
la fédération même d'apprécier de police
sur dix ans et péter sunde dans l'est
dans les pc vous êtes bien tous autour
des écrans avoir dit non non on était au
pcc hu est ce donc d'après aux polices
donc c'est c'est regarder les images
transports c'est une vocation pour gérer
la sécurité dans les transports et on
n'a pas de renvoi d'image ailleurs que
dans les réseaux de transport le préfet
de police étaient ou à ce moment là
on nous a dit qu'il était aussi c'est
vrai c'est qu'il avait pris la décision
du cc os d'interrompre le pré filtrage
donc il a bien des informations à ce
moment là
on ne peut pas répondre à la plage du
prophète prisme moi je vous réponds que
la vocation du cio s au sein duquel nous
sommes c'est de gérer la sécurité des
transports
messieurs avant de donner la parole aux
collègues et des lan collaborateurs très
proches un commissaire d'ailleurs qu'il
est à celle ratp qui était présent c'est
souvent ce qui est jean prendra pas
entrer en discussion sont in organisé ce
qui apparaît clair en tous les cas c'est
que si quelqu'un avait dû vous donner
une instruction en disant voilà ce qui
se passe il faut modifier votre
dispositif se seraient venus
principalement pour des difficultés de
l'autorité préfectorale principalement
c'est difficile que ça vienne d'ailleurs
puisque d'accord c'est bien et ça n'est
pas venu ça c'est clair aussi on va
donner la parole à michel savin je
propose qu'on la donne ensuite à jacques
grosperrin puis ensuite à madame de la
gontrie après monsieur lozach et
monsieur hervé comme ça chacun est en
capacité à se préparer et d'affûter ses
questions courtes en l'occurrence courte
monsieur ça va
merci messieurs les présidents
et messieurs - la question va revenir
sur les trente à quarante mille
personnes qui n'avaient pas de billets
ou qu'ils possédaient de faux billets
monsieur le ministre nous en rappeler
que ce chiffre était
qu'ils étaient présents donc aux portes
du stade de france et qui n'étaient pas
autorisés à entrer dans le stade de
france aurait donc après
21h30 donc un peu le début du match
disparus et opprimés
de coupure mais michel on ne t'entend
plus
je le coupé ma caméra on est là
alors oui oui en tentant
oui donc bull ministre de l'intérieur
des belles 2h45 d'après la sncf et selon
des images de vidéo protection les quais
du rer notamment de la station de la
plaine de stade de france était plein de
maillot rouge or maillot rouge donc de
liverpool or selon
ile-de-france mobilité il n'y aurait pas
eu d'arrivée tarder massy
à cette heure ci est selon le communiqué
de la sncf
ce que je relis rien de particulier n'a
été constaté au niveau des retours à 22h
en termes d'afflux que ce soit au niveau
du rer b ou rer b la sncf précisé même
qu'aucun flux particulier aux plus
importants que d'habitude n'a été
enregistré dans l'autre sens après le
début du match donc c'est un peu
contradictoire avec ce que dit debise de
l'intérieur alors voulez vous nous
expliquer la réelle situation que vous
avez connues notamment à aujourd'hui je
viens d'entendre matin qui nous dit vous
nous parlez de voir arriver du monde en
parle le match le monde c'est comme une
personne est ce que c'est les 30 à 40 me
qui n'ont pas pu rendre au stade et qui
serait arrivé c'est pas du mandat c'est
vraiment une foule importante puisqu'ils
auraient repris les transports en commun
et d'autres bars théâtres travail ô vous
nous dit aussi qu'au débat ces trains
n'étaient pas remplies parce que les
spectateurs restaurer sur les t bonds
que je pense que là il ya un vrai
problème de communication de
transparence à avoir est ce qu'il y
avait vraiment les printemps 40 milles
qui n'ont pas pu rentrer en plus les
transports à partir de 22 heures
jacques grosperrin
il n'estime c'est le président moi j'ai
entendu à plusieurs reprises
que vous avez dit que vous n'avez pas
une information de la fédération
française de foot je n'avais pas eu
d'information de la préfecture de police
et que vous avez répondu à cela que une
adaptation était possible donc ma
première question et qui aurait dû vous
appelez qui aurait dû vous dire vous
prévenir des différents types de
problèmes le deuxième point c'est que la
fédération française de foot avait
préparé une signalétique suite aux
grèves de l'oeil et de la ratp la
préfecture de police leur a demandé de
démonter ces panneaux d'orientation donc
de voyageurs et regarder vers le rer b
pourquoi vous ne les avez pas
réinstaller et pourquoi ça n'a pas été
fait et qui aurait dû vous demander de
faire cela donc on sent bien qu'ils
aient des difficultés
d'information dans les dispositions
d'information et d'adaptation qui soit
défaillant merci messieurs les prises
jean-jacques jean jacques lozach
merci président
je voudrais revenir sur la question de
la conservation des images
qui n'ont que l'intérêt d'essayer de
comprendre ce qui s'est passé et de
prévenir pour l'avenir donc à écouter
les deux entreprises
la ratp n'a pas conservé la sncf a
conservé mais avec ce détail qui est
curieux parce qu'il y avait eu un
incident entre
en gare de saint denis je crois voilà
mais quelque chose qui m'intrigue vous
voulez dire que alors que toutes les
chaînes du monde
montrait des images de ce qui s'était
passé personnes dans aucune de vos deux
entreprises s'est dit il faut garder des
images c'est un truc enfin
c'est un truc incroyable et la sncf ne
les gardent que parce que heureusement
qu'il ya un incident à saint denis donc
c'est je ne comprends pas que vous ayez
été aussi inadaptées au contexte et donc
que vous n'ayez pas eu l'idée de votre
propre chef de conserver ces images jean
jacques lozach
vous voyez merci président bon vous
savez depuis le début des auditions on a
quand même le sentiment que les
différents acteurs de la soirée du 28
mai se refile à la patate chaude et se
renvoient la responsabilité de cette non
de désordre donc je reviens je reviens
et vous allez voir pourquoi sur ce
problème de l'information s'est
recueilli les propos très fermes de la
directrice générale de la fédération
française de football notamment donc sur
ces informations concernant le
détournement des flux du rp du rer b
vers le rer d et ce manque d'information
a créé donc des des problèmes
d'engorgement alors c'est vrai que suite
à cette audition vous avez apporté un
démenti mais j'aurais savoir donc
aujourd'hui vous confirmer devant nous
deux commissions sénatoriales ce manque
d'information ou si vous confirmez le
démenti vous avez apporté ensuite
pourquoi je dis ça parce que depuis
cette audition la fédération française
de foot on a pris connaissance du
rapport du préfet michel cadot et il
parle notamment de défaillance en ce qui
concerne ce dispositif d'information et
d'insuffisance même d'informations entre
notamment la ratp et les postes de
commandement deuxième manche et s'est
lié aussi à l'information et ça a été
effleurée par le collègue grosperrin
tout à l'heure et ça on n'en n'avait pas
connaissance et jusqu'à présent et sa
figure dans le rapport cadeaux c'est ce
problème de signalétique quand même
parce que c'est quand même assez
étonnant cette affaire c'est à dire que
la grève de la ratp étaient connus et
ses conséquences sur l'orientation des
flux aussi la fédération de près par une
signalétique d'orientation c'est la page
11 du rapport
c'est la page on je vais pas la relire
mais enfin le préfet arrive à la
conclusion il aurait été souhaitable que
cette signalétique soul réinstallé dès
le risque de perturbations connues en
toute connaissance de cause donc
effectivement pourquoi là il n'y a pas
eu en tire corriger au cours de cette
soirée et puis enfin une question un peu
plus générale et qui rejoint d'ailleurs
une des préconisations aussi de du
préfet qui qui dit qu' on a le sentiment
et c'est vrai que vous avez donc un
schéma appliqué le schéma d'organisation
à appliquer que vous rien juste est en
cours de route car il ya des imprévus ou
des difficultés qui apparaissent et lui
ce qu'ils proposent et jour de savoir ce
que vous en pensez c'est justement en
amant d'avoir bien d'avoir plusieurs
plans b c'est-à-dire d'avoir plusieurs
plusieurs scénarios différents que l'on
met en place suffisamment tôt dans la
journée ou dans la soirée voilà c'est là
aussi je dirais
reproche quand même assez fort et ses
puissants qui est exprimé par par le
préfet cadot sur ce manque
d'anticipation
loïc hervé
et merci messieurs les présidents madame
messieurs chers collègues moi ma
question sa fausse prendra part revient
évidemment sur la question des images de
vidéo protection
premièrement si le délai légal maximal
est de 30 jours le délégué de le délai
inférieur de quelques heures on a évoqué
72 heures est ce que c'est un délai si
vous êtes imposés par pas ce que fait le
préfet ou est ce que c'est un délai qui
est un délai technique liée à la
capacité de votre serveur à conserver
ces images ça c'est ma première question
est ce que c'est qu'une norme que vous
vous imposez techniquement ou est ce que
c'est une norme qui vous est imposée
manière réglementaire et l'autre
question c'est vous avez évoqué pour les
quelques images conservées dieu soit
loué que vous en ayez encore
quelques-unes à fournir aux autorités
judiciaires si par hasard elle vous lui
demandez
vous avez évoqué une procédure
remontantes c'est-à-dire un agent qui
constate la commission d'un délit you ou
un événement qui se passe dans une gare
très bien où ça on remonte au niveau
hiérarchique et on conserve les images
utile mais il n'y at il pas dans vos
processus internes 1 une décision
descendante c'est à dire que étant donné
le tumulte je reconnais que l'on évoqué
un temps donné le tumulte médiatique
politique judiciaire qui interviendrait
est-ce que de manière
descendante quelqu'un dans la hiérarchie
peut prendre la décision l'initiative de
dire là on a besoin de garder tel est l
image le temps que l'autorité judiciaire
voire d'autres d'autres autorités
prennent l'initiative de vous demander
les images merci
alors on va vous a laissé répondre cette
série de questions
je viens juste en guise d'introduction
sent qu'il ya une confusion entre
ce qui est du périmètre de nos emprises
et après ce qui est du périmètre du
stade de france donc nous d'abord nous
n'avons de vidéosurveillance que dans
nos rames et dans le périmètre de nos
installations et deuxièmement que ce
soit en anticipation ou un opérationnel
ce que nous indiquons c'est un plan de
transport et donc dès lors qu'on dit
qu'on va pour des raisons tenant la
grève ratp mais aussi parce que fan zone
cours de vincennes on va
vraisemblablement avoir plus de monde
sur le rer d on n'est pas en effet en
anticipation capable de dire jusqu'où ce
plus ce plus va monter par contre en
opérationnel et dans le cas précis de la
soirée du 28 à compter de 18h toutes les
demi heures nous transmettons les
informations au pc du stade ce terreau
coeur à partir de 18 heures le pc du
stade c'est comptage 18h05 ce stade de
france saint-denis
8660 la plaine-stade-de-france 1210 donc
on voit très vite il ya un gros écart
entre la dea et l'abbé on remet ça une
demi-heure après stade de france
saint-denis 16400 la plaine
la plaine de 1200 donc les informations
de la part du transporteur quant aux
flux sont partagés connu et nous n'avons
eu aucune alerte sur le thème il y a des
problèmes on absorbe plus donc retenu le
rer d je confirme que nous n'avons eu
aucune alerte
voilà monsieur martin oui
concernant dit au moment des flux du rer
b vais regarder le rapport cadeau
puisque la cité il dit page 11 la grève
ratp était connu et ses conséquences les
orientations de flux aussi donc il a
après son enquête l'ensemble des acteurs
le savez donc donc on savait qu'elle
était schéma précisé on a beaucoup de
plans de ceux de dégrader baissé on
mobilise salle de crise puisque notre
adn c'est justement de gérer les
incidents et d'imprévu dans les
transports en commun dont justement 6 1
à 6 ans technicien un problème si donc
on a toujours des plans pour de
substitution à faire alors qu'on est à
100% du service les marges sont plus
faibles mais on est en capacité de
pouvoir réagir
après sur le problème de une question
qui était posée sur les panneaux je
pense que ça c'est des panneaux qui sont
mis à l'extérieur qui sont pas d'emprise
que si le rapport cadeaux des preuves de
réorientation entre la préfecture et
paul dewil c'est pas un problème
transporter en tant que tel parce que
c'est des canalisations en gestion des
flux dès qu'on est sorti des emprises de
transport
comme ça sont des images merci sur les
images peut-être après vous vous
rappelez un peu à la ratp on a un parc
de plus de 50 mille caméras
dont 15000 sont dans les espaces dont
vous imaginez ce que ça peut représenter
un volume de stockage au quotidien ses
58 51 mille caméras aujourd'hui et qui
seront sans doute de l'ordre de 100
milles dans quelques années avec le
grand paris à chaque fois qu'un nouveau
matériel roulant arrive il est équipé de
vidéos ce qui n'est pas le cas des
anciens matériels roulants donc pour des
raisons effectivement technique et nous
ne sommes pas les seuls je le serai un
chef le dire mais on a limité on limite
la capacité
d'enregistrement ce sont 12 heures c'est
une capacité d'enregistrement qui est
connu de tous puisque on traite 7000
réquisition par an je rappelle quand
même que donc on est réquisitionné 7000
fois par an pour nous demander des
images vidéo donc c'est quelque chose
qui est connu et habituel il n'y a pas
des y'a pas de sujet sur sa durée de
conservation elle est connue il ya des
raisons techniques viennent nous les
expliquer
si demain il faut passer sur des durées
un peu plus longues il y aura
effectivement des choix avec l'autorité
organisatrice d'investissements
conséquents à faire pour les conserver
ensuite les traiter pourquoi on les a
pas conserver le soir du 28 mai comme on
l'a dit plusieurs reprises on a eu aucun
incident notable sur nos emprises nos
caméras on l'a dit aussi le film que
nous réseau donc au quotidien dans une
ville comme paris dans une région comme
l'île de france il y à des incidents à
l'extérieur de nos de nos espaces et
pour autant pour autant conserve pas des
images qui pourraient être utiles et
donc quand la police pour les autorités
judiciaires estiment que par contre
parce qu'il ya une année si donc il
s'est passé en dehors de nos espaces
pourraient nos caméras pourraient t'être
utiles on est réquisitionnée je vous
renvoie au 7 mai réquisitions qui
concerne effectivement des incidents
dans le réseau mais qui peuvent parfois
concernés pour des raisons d' enquêtes
des incidents en dehors de nos emprises
donc nous appartenions n'était pas
réquisitionné et qu'il n'y avait eu
aucun incident dans nos réseaux
effectivement il n'y avait pas de raison
objective de conserver ces images je
vous rappelle que la vidéoprotection et
accessoirement aussi très encadrés par
la cnil donc on espère qu on respecte
les procédures que l'on met en place
dans l'entreprise
je me permets de reprendre la parole
y a pas eu d'incident l'égard de vos
personnels
d'accord non cette importance que de le
dire parce qu'il ya un certain nombre de
témoignages de bruits qui circulent
autant qu'on sache clairement les choses
il avoue qu'il pouvait nous dire
réellement ce qu'il en est pardon de
prolonger la question du président
buffet mais j'ai noté quand même dans le
rapport du préfet cadot qui le disaient
que des équipes du transilien sncf se
sont repliés jolie la phrase
temporairement pour ne plus être exposés
à certains délinquants il ya bien eu des
incidents qui ont concerné le personnel
alors
il ya eu à vers 23h45 23h50 sur la
plaine saint-denis donc la gare du rer b
il y avait beaucoup de monde sur la
grande esplanade qui est devant devant
la gare
et dans ces cas là il ya de la rétention
par les forces de l'ordre les équipes de
la sûreté ferroviaire qui elle reste
évidemment aux abords immédiats de la
gare de manière à ce que les voyageurs
rentrent graduellement dans la gare et
descendent en toute sûreté sur les quais
ce que nos agents ont observé et qui
d'ailleurs a fait l'objet d'un procès
verbal de renseignements de la part de
la police des transports ce qu'ils ont
observé ce et des jets de projectiles
bouteilles et autres sur la rampe ouest
et donc les agents eux-mêmes je parle
pas évidemment de la sûreté ferroviaire
mais les agents eux-mêmes se sont
repliées près des automates et autres
déchets et puis ont ouvert les ce qu'on
appelle les caves donc tout ce qui est
tourniquet de validation tout simplement
parce qu'il constatait et je reprends
leurs mots des supporters de liverpool
très énervé particulièrement avinés qui
bousculait les gilets rouges qui
bousculait les agents mais bon rien rien
de grave il ya toujours des veines
événement stade de france ça a été par
contre vu par nos agents des choses
qu'ils connaissent très rarement à la
sortie à la sortie d'un stade de france
l'autre élément qu'ils ont noté c'était
la forte présence de pickpockets de
pickpockets sur les quais voilà donc il
ya eu une sortie à la fin du match aux
alentours de 23h45 qui était
hors norme tendu très tendu tendue mais
pas d'agents qui ont été pas d'agents
qui ont été nos agents gardons ces cas
là font appel à la sûreté ferroviaire et
aux forces de police et la sûreté les
forces sont venus et en un quart d'heure
on a à peu près rétabli
un peu d'ordre et donc l'évacuation à
puces continue et se poursuivre dans des
conditions dans des conditions correctes
alors ouais
et qui ont été posées qui n'ont pas été
auxquels vous n'avez pas répondu d'abord
sur la signalétique je ne sais plus je
crois que c'est jacques grosperrin qui
posait la question de la suppression de
la signalétique
sur les images vidéo il ya eu plusieurs
séries de questions
qui ont été posées notamment sur vos
processus internes est ce que quelqu'un
pouvait décider
et puis sur les différents scénarios que
de transport et est-ce que ç'avait été
disons
sur le sujet des vidéos comme je vais
indiquer pour être plus précise comme il
y avait eu une rixe qui a été connue en
gare de saint denis le dimanche 29 mai à
10h29 un agent sur celui qui sait
sollicitation du chef de salle du poste
de commandement national sûreté assure
la protection des vidéos de la gare et
puis on a eu la même chose le 31 compte
tenu des évènements que je viens
rapidement de relater sur sur la partie
la plaine stade de france ces deux types
d'événements qui nous ont conduit les
équipes en l'occurrence le chef du pc
sûreté à a demandé le blocage de blocage
des vidéos
via les tic personne n'intervient parce
que la signalétique j'ai repris la page
en ce que vous avez eu la gentillesse de
nous mentionner
le président et c'est une signalétique
qui n'est pas dans nos emprises c'est
clairement la signalétique la fff avait
préparé une signalétique d'orientation à
cet effet elle relate coq en les noyant
la préfecture de seine-saint-denis le 23
la préfecture de police a demandé de
faire démonter les panneaux prévoyant de
l'orientation des voyageurs sortant du r
vrd vers le cheminement de sortie du rer
b va donc on est vraiment sur la voie
publique est hors de nos entreprises
dernière question est une
question précise encore
le mercredi qui suit le match
on auditionne monsieur darmanin ministre
de l'intérieur et dans la conversation
et notamment répondre une question à
marie pierre de la gontrie sur les
images déjà qui
la question était sur justement les flux
et ses deux petites questions des 30 40
milles où ils sont passés etc
il a dit textuellement à ce moment-là
ya des images de la ratp vous pourrez
visionner ses réussites
quelle image
c'est dans son audition je vais je les
isoler donc je vous dirais qu'à kehl à
quel endroit exactement on est le
mercredi soit à peine plus de trois
jours on va dire on va dire on est
encore dans des donc lui nous parle
d'image qu'on pourra voir alors qu'elle
était en train de s'écraser
et personne n'a réagi à ce moment là je
trouve tout cela très étonnant en fait
je vous confirme monsieur le sénateur
après donc des initiatives qui était
interne que je vous ai relaté
le mercredi 1er juin après midi à la
demande du sdr péter donc la police des
transports sous direction régionale de
la police des transports dans la tente
d' éventuelles réquisitions les
séquences vidéo des garçons préserver
contre l'effacement automatique donc on
a eu un appel le 1er juin après midi de
la part de la sous direction de la
police des transports
on paie le même appel si nous aurions
pris la même décision
gare principale qui est lié et sans
doute qu'ils étaient surtout peut-être
comme comme l'arabie saoudite charles
les plus sensibles c'était celle du du
stade de france elle est exploitée par
la sncf peut-être j'essaie d'expliquer
ça comme ça
oui bien sûr mais je ne prends pas avec
la vidéo c'est pas un sujet sur lequel
on s'amuse on entend personnellement je
lis à des procédures et je pense qu'il
est plutôt important de les respecter
quand elles sont mises en oeuvre et si
on n'est pas réquisitionné on n'est pas
sauf un incident je pense que nous
n'avons pas c'est quand même quelque
chose d'encadrer je pense que l'averse
on nous le reprocherait si on stockait
des images au delà des procédures que
l'on met en place
juste pour bien comprendre la
territoriale des transports c'est une
entité sous l'autorité du préfet de
police donc le préfet de police vous
aviez demandé via la territoriale des
transports enfin en tout cas à la sncf
de conserver les images le mercredi
bien peut-être avant de une dernière
question
qui est plus prospective face à cette
expérience malheureuse disons les choses
telles qu'elles sont la france organise
l'année prochaine coupe du monde de
rugby dans deux ans les jeux olympiques
et les jeux paralympiques
que retenez-vous comme le sont et comme
améliorations à faire dans le dispositif
tel qu'il existe aujourd'hui tel qu'il a
été vécue aujourd'hui
à via un collègue par donc lé de cairns
non mais c'est très bien parce que le
président du fai vient de poser ma
question
et michel savin qui est épié après on
s'arrêtera là et michel savin
oui même si j'aurais voulu avoir une
réponse la question que j'ai posée
président
concernant la communication qui est
complètement opposé entre la sncf qui
nous préciser aucun flux particulier les
important n'a été enregistré après le
début du match et
la communication du ministre de
l'intérieur qui me dit que lui à mieux
que beaucoup de personnes des milliers
de personnes avaient repris donc et
transport après le début de match quand
il ya une contradiction entre les deux
communications quelle est la bonne
communication
si monsieur ça va
mal à monsieur dans l'ordre que vous
souhaitez alors je confirme que vers
22h50 nous avons vu plus de monde que
d'habitude puisque d'habitude on a du
monde une fois le match terminé alors
que là le match n'était pas terminée
donc je ne pense pas
je pense avoir été mal comprise par
monsieur sénateurs voilà
pour le rythme termine et madame charles
souple pour le reste en termes
d'amélioration
mon collègue éric martin il ya fait
allusion on a un souci dans le cadre de
l'exercice du droit de grève puisque la
dernière loi en ce domaine est un petit
peu contournée par des préavis dormant
c'est à dire que bien que parfois
n'ayant plus de grévistes ou un seul
gréviste
le préavis a été considérée par la
chambre sociale de la cour de cassation
comme toujours valide et donc nous
n'avons pas une anticipation du coup
très importante et d'ailleurs à ma
connaissance c'est bien sûr un préavis
dormant que le mouvement ratp a été
déclenchée donc donc ça fait parti des
améliorations qui pourraient quand même
nous permettre en tout cas de mieux
partager de mieux partager les choses
l'autre amélioration de notre côté nous
avons été frappé par la différence
entre
la précision des chiffres anticipée par
le real de madrid et la non précision
pour rester dans des paroles
douces de celle de liverpool sterckx on
avait très très peu de choses précises
et en particulier on n'a pas du tout
anticipé que des supporters avaient dû
arriver en avance et bien que munich
billets étaient allés à la fan zone d'où
d'ailleurs un afflux qui a été je trouve
extrêmement bien géré notamment par nos
collègues de la ratp qui avait fait le
chemin avec des collaborateurs de la
préfecture de police donc on a ce
problème de l'anticipation de
l'anticipation des des flux qui me
paraît important après en opérationnel à
l'évidence gérer des flux sait les faire
de bout en bout et
on doit pouvoir avoir des dispositifs
qui jusqu'au bout c'est-à-dire jusqu'au
stade s'adapte en fonction des chiffres
qui sont transmis et réciproquement nous
pouvoir nous adapter ce qu'on a su me
semble-t-il
assez bien faire mais au regard des
chiffres qui ont été transmis toutes les
demi heures à partir de 18h05 et où on a
vu très vite que la dea était très forte
par rapport à l'année on peut en effet
s'étonner qu'ils aient pas eu
d'adaptation
côté sur les entrées stade de france
monsieur martin oui oui donc
on partage le problème là dès ce qu'on
appelle les préavis illimités donc on a
des préavis illimités on encore 21 ratp
sur lequel chaque agent peut se déclarer
de lui-même à tout moment ce qui fait
que pour se mouvant 10,28 il n'y a pas
eu de d'armes sociale ni trabi devrait
déposer les agences sont organisées au
dernier moment pour organiser un
mouvement et donc pour faire un peu d
organisation
et nous la règle 48 heures 24 heures et
a quitté pékin on travaille beaucoup ce
sujet là et on souhaiterait peut-être
que les déclarations passe de 48 à 72
heures et le changement date 24 à 48
heures donc ça va perdre et avoir une
organisation plus robuste d'informer
plus en amont les voyageurs et
partenaires ça peut être une petite
amélioration sur ce sujet là si on peut
avancer deuxième sujet c'est je crois la
chaîne de bout en bout parce qu'on voit
bien que on a beaucoup communiqué sur
notre plan de transport on a beaucoup
échangé on a bien travaillé qu'un
panneau de police et près de
sécurisation dans nos espaces on n'a pas
eu ce problème la fan zone si bien passé
on n'a pas beaucoup de visibilité ce qui
se passait après la gestion des flux les
double filtrage ce que dit le rapport
cadeaux et peut-être qu'il faudrait
peut-être que on se plus grande
intégration de l'ensemble du système de
la chaîne de bout en bout qu'on puisse
participer pour leur dire attention
parce que vous y avoir seuil et qu'on
soit peut-être plus tous ensemble autour
d'eux du projet enfin message
d'optimisme on a su gérer tous les
événements c'est de france depuis plus
de 20 ans la coupe du monde de foot en
98 c'est une coupe du monde de rugby en
2007 j'aurais dû mandater 6 en 2003
d'état de match ont donc voila c'était
des situations très particulières avec
beaucoup de spectateurs beaucoup de
spectateurs étrangers organisé un petit
peu d'éléments enfin voilà donc on a
fait vraiment tous ses efforts je pense
que le délai court d'organisation aussi
à peut-être pas facilité aux
organisateurs la pression de police des
trois mois de décision mais je pense que
les accès vraiment de mettre encore plus
alors qu'ils ont été encore plus tous
les acteurs tous la table pour pouvoir
échanger pour pouvoir ce challenge et
sur la gestion des flux quand on a bien
vu que le problème sa gestion des flux
et puis trouver des solutions de
canalisations d'information
d'orientation ce qu'on a fait au stade
de france pour la ligne 12 quittez pas
une ligne classique depuis qu'il ya des
travaux ça au stade de france on
travaille à l'émission axes au nord et
l'émission fait par l'état et dans
lequel on à flécher des gens voyageant
pour aller prendre la ligne 12 pour
justement éclater les flux et d'éviter
sur l'affluence voilà c'est tout ce que
je peux vous proposer
merci merci madame merci messieurs pour
votre présence ce matin notre séance est
levée merci